hi i'm rita ora and i am doing the wired
auto complete interview
let me know if my posture starts going
like this
because my mother will kill me if my
posture is bad
okay
here we go
what is rita ora
known for well you know i get asked that
a lot because i do lots of things i do
music
i do film i do tv shows and i do fashion
i really love doing everything and you
know why because why not all right 360
artist businesswoman what
here's the next one
what is rita ora's vocal range well
first of all what is rita ora's
vocal range i mean i don't know how to
say it but you know it really is a very
kind of strong one it really varies
depending on the record but i'd like to
think i'm a very
strong alto i got that husk
what does root aura look like what
google images people google images okay
i look like this
instagram handle at retort what is rita
ora
zodiac sign
my zodiac sign
is sagittarius 26th of november 1990
which i think in the united states of
america that's around thanksgiving all
my american friends seem to be
unavailable around my birthday so are
they really my friends i don't really
know
what is rita ora's most popular song
well
i think there's a few anywhere is a
pretty good one i will never let you
down i did with calvin harris oh and let
you love me i'm also just telling you
the songs that i love performing so
what connects rita ora and oh there's
two
and
oh jim belushi well we're both from the
same country from kosovo there's
actually a lot of incredible artists now
coming out of my country i'm very proud
of it but yes he is an icon where i'm
from
what has rita ora done to her hair
what
so i'm not quite sure so people are
actually asking these questions because
they don't like what i've done to my
hair
or they want to know how to do my hair
or they want to copy it i'm quite sure
where i stand there without question
i've done a lot of looks i've shaved my
head done a little sort of crop do
i've gone all sorts of colors platinum
blue purple pink what does rita ora eat
everything
what are rita ora's fans called well
the ritabots you know i'm not quite sure
where they got that from what they say
to me is you know like they're they're
robots they're indestructible so
that is i think where they got rita bots
are robots bots
what was rita ora's first song well
it was a song called r.i.p
it was written actually by drake and
chase and status
and it's probably
one of the most memorable moments of my
life of course it was my first song was
the first time i had a solo number one
single the one prior to that was a
feature so i don't really technically
cast it as my record you know so this
for me was a monumental moment
is rita ora
albanian yes well let me just tell you
it's a bit complicated right kosovo is
now independent which it wasn't back in
the day so technically yes for years i
would say i'm albanian i'm albanian
albanian but i'm actually kosovan but
it's really very
much it's similar
is ritora her real name you know it's so
funny everyone asks me that it really is
my my full name is rita sahachu aura
israeli torah left-handed yes i am
i'm pretty happy to be left-handed
because they say a lot of good things
about left-handed people you know
they're creative they're loving they're
lovable they're awesome
they're amazing people
friendly
kind generous
funny
just doesn't end
what
do i need to say this one
yeah
okay
does rita aura oh this one's kind of
tricky i already can feel it does
gosh i don't even know okay here we go
does rita aura
sing in 50 shades yes i do i am in 50
shades and i sing in 50 shades it's a
song called for you that i do with liam
payne i kind of love singing for film
you know i've done a song for detective
pikachu i did the for you soundtrack i
really feel like i love it because you
already have a visual you know so
writing songs for movies is really fun
because you can really adapt to what
you're watching
does ritora speak albanian yes i do i
mean i can say si ayamir which means hi
how are you gesuard means cheers and not
nemir means goodnight my parents growing
up
spoke
albanian in the house
constantly they were learning how to
speak english at the same time so i kind
of just really picked it up and thank
goodness they did because it's really
nice speaking another language
especially in public if other people
don't understand what you're saying
does rita ora write her own songs yeah
some of them i do some of them have been
written already and then i put my thing
on them it really depends on the song
you know i really feel like however a
song comes into my life comes in
for a reason so i tend to mold it to me
it's hot in here when was rita ora born
okay i was born 26th of november 1990
i'm a 90's baby when was rita ora on the
voice
well i'm on it a few times actually i
did it back home in the uk i was a coach
back in i think 2014 or 15 and then i
just wrapped up doing the voice
australia when is rita ora on tour i
know right
hopefully i'll be on tour 2022 fingers
crossed watch out for the tickets
when was rita ora
oh sorry
when was rita ora a judge on x factor
wow that was pretty
pretty it was a while ago i would say
2013 no 14 gosh it was my first kind of
tv gig i loved it i i went back as an
actual
judge at some point and it was really
cool and i actually won the show
thank you okay who is rita ora
best friend who is my best friend
i've got a few i'm very lucky i've got
amazing friends well first of all my
bestest friend is somebody i went and
grew up with back at home who i've known
since i was one years old she's the best
she really loves to stay out of the
spotlight so i won't say her name but
she is really my rock aside from that i
have made some incredible friends in the
industry who i cast as my dearest
friends and i love them to bits charli
xcx being one charlie is for me one of
the most talented people ever to be on
planet earth she's such a great writer
she is one of the funnest people to
party with i think she is just like
the coolest you know you know some
people are just like that's cool that's
charlie
who has rita ora collaborated with i
like collaborating i can admit i have
had a few collaborations in my career
thus far dj fresh who is an amazing dj
we had the first drum and bass number
one single which in history dj tiesto
alesso
kygo calvin harris
avicii
oh gosh david guetta emma beck now
cigala gosh i'm sorry if i'm missing out
on any other djs
who has rita ora
guest on the masked
singer
i guessed neo
ceelo green kalis
you know i've guessed a lot because i
love music you know for me it's like
muscle memory i hear the tone and i'm
like i know exactly who that is and i
can really take the game kind of
seriously the rest of the judges are
like can you relax it's a game show i'm
like no i need to get this right
who is ritora's sister well her name is
elena aura she is fun great fantastic
and she works with me
here we are
how was rita ora discovered
well i didn't really get signed until i
was 14 to 16 and that was just a
production deal that fell through i
ended up working in a recording studio
to get sort of like free studio time and
through that i met a lot of singers i
did a lot of backing vocals for a lot of
people on albums that you probably have
heard and
wouldn't know it was me on there and
then you know i would write a lot of
demos for a lot of people and it got
into the hands of rock nation and jay-z
luckily they liked it they flew me out
to new york and by the time i turned 17
i was signed to up nation that's the
quick version by the way
how tall is route to aurora well i'd
like to think i'm 5 11 but nobody
believes me i'm more like five seven
five six five seven yeah i think being
tall is gorgeous i don't know ever since
i was young i wanted to be like really
tall so weird right
how old is rita ora okay i just
gonna say it i'm 30
yes i made it you know i think being 30
is amazing i feel very calm i feel very
much more aware of myself i think in
your 20s you're not meant to know what's
going on you're meant to just figure it
all out you know so don't put too much
pressure on yourself but i do feel very
confident and comfortable in my skin
being 30 and i think that's a very sexy
thing yeah i feel very like
in myself
how to be rita or
what
i can't believe people actually type
these things how do you i mean
how to be me well i mean
i don't know i guess just be ambitious
you know be proud of who you are where
you're from and
never really give up until you know
you've you've tried everything
how is ritora
ah
that's so nice
you know no one really asks you that
i'm fine thank you
ah since you mentioned it well there was
this guy and there was this not joking
i'm absolutely fine thank you very much
for asking how are you
how
many tattoos
does rita ora have sorry mum if you're
watching
i have a lot you know i think i just
made a decision and i became like a
tattoo girl you know it started
kind of early on in my in my life like
in my early 20s and it just really never
ended so
i've probably got about 30. i think now
i think i will only get something if
it's really
really important you know what i mean if
it's like a memory or somebody that i
really you know if it's just something
very special then yeah well alright
that's it till next time i hope you've
had fun i've had a great time some of
the questions i can't believe that they
get typed but you know that's what we
are here to do thanks for watching i had
an amazing time
[Music]
you